okay let's get into this week's hatred
mail continuing to debut new hey tree at
male intros new hatred mail banners and
all sorts of very very exciting stuff
let's take a listen to what hatred mail
is first and foremost it's like email
forwards from your racist grandma on
steroids Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom yes so this
week's hatred mail touching a lot of the
common themes of hatred mail that many
of you are now familiar with there is
anti-semitism there is conspiratorial
thinking there is bad grammar all of the
stuff it's sort of an all of the above
day on hatred mail let's take a listen
to this one
why does David Park man sound like he's
constantly demanding to speak to my
manager liberal self-hating Jew who the
[ __ ] are you and how much did you donate
to the Clinton Foundation does George
Soros produce this shirt and pay for
your microphone David Hartman you know
what's funny about this and by funny I
mean absolutely tragic would George
Soros really even have an interest in
funding our show Pat I mean Soros has an
insane amount of money and he uses that
money for activism but it's not
practical when you're at his level of
philanthropy I think to be involved in
funding shows as small as ours quite
frankly I mean it with that money he can
very quickly go all the way to the top
like the idea that he would even waste
time at the micro level it's flattering
in a way but it also shows not
surprisingly that these hate rates have
no idea how anything works well George
Soros he does not fund the show he does
not give any money to you directly every
now and then he'll give me something to
keep me going but I'm trying to maintain
that it has no impact on what I say on
the show and this may be news to you too
but
I try to keep it under wraps normally oh
dear okay that will be edited out of the
program before the the program goes out
I say that now because someone when we
were talking of how the david pakman
show bingo card either the hatred mail
bingo card or just the normal one
somebody submitted as a possible bingo
card item david says something will be
edited out which of course is a joke it
never is the idea is that we don't edit
anything out because the show is it's
live to tape as if it were a completely
live show and then people will always
write in pat and they'll say hey i think
pat messed up he didn't edit out that
thing he was supposed to edit out but
it's a joke we're not really looking to
any edit anything out just so you also
know pat and you don't find that stuff
out I see that in the YouTube comments
all the time like this was left in you
were supposed to take this out it's just
an ongoing joke that we have and I like
it okay if you want to make 422 hatreds
cry while saving 40% you can use the
coupon code hey tree at 40 when you sign
up for membership at www.engvid.com
coupon code hey tree at 40 you say 40%
you get a hundred percent of the member
benefits 422 hey tree it's cry it is
like a middle finger to the hey tree
'it's please do it support the show
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash pakman blinka is a
great service that i use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and i've
listened to a ton of books on blinka s--
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book of BS jobs by David
Graeber which I listen to on bling cos
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform
you will never run out of fascinating
and critically acclaimed books to enjoy
and our audience can get a seven day
free trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa que mas